ON AGRICULTURE WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD MORNING A RESPONSE
THE KOBE NINETEEN EMERGENCY I
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
THAT HERE'S SOCIAL DISTANCING
ENTRIES COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE OF THESE ORDERS- THE
SET HAS MADE HISTORY JUST
MISTRAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC USED HAVE
ACCESS TO LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE- STREET
BUILDING. AND THIS IS MY FIRST
TIME IN THIS IN THIS ROOM IT'S
LOVELY SO AS ALL MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM
TO THE EXTENT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS HELLO IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
OPPOSED OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AS WELL AND I ALSO WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW DAYS BUT IT'S BEEN NUMBER
IS 877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR
SIX TWO FOR DETAILED.
INSTRUCTIONS HOW TO LOOKING. TO
MORE EXPOSURE TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
UPPER TO CITING THE LINE NUMBER
THIS COULD BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME WILL BE ON
MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE SHOULD YOU
WISH. PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY IN AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING- THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I
WILL DO MY UTMOST TO MAINTAIN
DECORUM WITH THIS RAUCOUS GROUP
THAT WE HAVE AG COMMITTEE- ARE
AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS TO MUTED. WE ARE.
WHEN WE GIVE OURSELVES ABOUT
SIXTY SECONDS. IN HOPES THAT-
OUR ESTEEMED COLLEAGUES ARRIVE
IT IS TEN O'CLOCK WILL START AT
TEN A ONE.
OKAY NOW THAT OUR ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE IS HERE- WE HAVE TWO
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA SO I
IMAGINE IT WILL GO RATHER
QUICKLY BEFORE WE AGREES HERE
PRESENTATION ON BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM CONSULTING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FORGES
PRESENT FOR JUST PRESENT HER
TADO CABALLERO CARILLO PRESENT
EGGMAN GLAZER HERE. GLAZER HERE
. ALL RIGHT WE ARE ONLY WAITING
ON- SENATOR HER TADO CENTER
EGGMAN WILL NOT BE PRESENT TODAY
THE CONSOLE NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED NOW LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR THANK YOU
FOR PATIENTLY WAITING CENTER
LAYERED- ME PLEASE PRESENT S. B.
NINE EIGHT TWO. LATER TO
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED IN ALICE'S-
IN YOUR PRESENTATION IF YOU
COULD IDENTIFY CENTER LAYERED IF
YOU WILL BE ACCEPTING THESE-
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON S. B. NINE EIGHTY TWO AND I
WILL ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE LISTED ON
PAGE FOUR OF THE- COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCES. A SENATE BILL NINE
EIGHTY TO ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA
APPLE COMMISSION TO CREATE AN
ORGANIC APPLE CERTIFICATION. A
PROGRAM SUBJECT TO APPROVAL BY
THE SECRETARY OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE THE CALIFORNIA APPLE
COMMISSION WILL COVER THE COST
OF THE PROGRAM- THROUGH THEIR
DUES THE CENTRAL COAST IS HOME
TO OVER 20% OF APPLE ACREAGE IN
THE STATE. MAKING IT THE SECOND
LARGEST PRODUCER OF APPLES IN
CALIFORNIA AFTER ABOUT THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY OF DELTA. WHEN
THE CONSUMERS PURCHASE- ORGANIC
PRODUCE THEY'RE PAYING FOR IT
EXPECTING A CERTAIN QUALITY OF
GOODS RECENTLY HOWEVER APPLES
ARE BEING IMPORTED INTO
CALIFORNIA LABELED AS ORGANIC
BUT TREATED WITH THE NON ORGANIC
PRESERVATIVE. OF METAL
CYCLOPROPANE WHICH IS KNOWN AS
M. C. P. AND ALL REFER TO WHAT
IS THAT GOING FORWARD. WHILE MCP
IS SAFE TO USE ON PRODUCE AND
IMPROVE STORAGE AND FOOD QUALITY
IT IS NOT DEEMED ORGANIC BY
CALIFORNIA STANDARDS NOT ONLY
DOES THIS PRACTICE DECEIVE
CONSUMERS AND PUT THE INTEGRITY
OF CALIFORNIA STATE ORGANIC
PROGRAM RISK. IT UNDERCUTS LOCAL
ORGANIC APPLE PRODUCERS I
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE PRINCIPLE
SEE WHEN IT COMES TO THE FOOD
THEY EAT AND OUR APPLE PRODUCER
SHOULD NOT HAVE. TO FACE UNFAIR
COMPETITION- S. B. EIGHTY TWO
ONE THAT ORGANIC APPLES GO
THROUGH A CERTIFICATION PROCESS
TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT APPLE'S
MARKET IN CALIFORNIA. AS ORGANIC
ARE COMPLIANT. A SINCE THE
ANALYSIS OF THE CALIFORNIA APPLE
COMMISSION INDICATED THEIR
SUPPORT AND THE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU WROTE A LETTER IN
SUPPORT. OF WITH ME TO TESTIFY
IS TODD SANDERS WHO'S THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA APPLE COMMISSION- I
APPRECIATE OF THE HEARING AND
RESPECTFUL ASTRONOMICAL. THANK
YOU WELL WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
ANYONE WISHING TO SEE- TESTIFIED
SUPPORT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TO COLLEGE CONSIDERATIONS
INCLUDING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRS- MANSE TO TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED IN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR OF LIMIT WILL BE TO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION EACH
WITNESS WHAT TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY ALL OTHERS WISHING TEST
WHY MUSLIM OF THE COMMENTS TO
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THE MEASURES. IN FOR THOSE ME
TOOS PLEASE DO NOT PROVIDE A
NARRATIVE SIMPLY IDENTIFY
YOURSELF BY NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ONLY- SO AS AN EARLIER
INDICATED- HIS WITNESS IS TAUGHT
SANDERS FROM AT CALIFORNIA APPLE
COMMISSION- DO WE HAVE MISTER
SANDERS ON THE LINE. YES CENTER
I'M HERE. THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MISTER SANDERS. FIRST
I THINK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AND
TO EVERYBODY AND PART OF THAT
ARE- JUST WANTED TO. GIVE A
COUPLE OF QUICK DETAIL- I'VE
BEEN INSTRUCTED TO DEFEAT ALL-
KEEP IT AS SHORT AS POSSIBLE- AT
THE SENATOR AT YES CALIFORNIA
PRODUCES ROUGHLY ABOUT ONE. AND
A HALF MILLION BOXES OF FRESH
APPLES ANNUALLY ABOUT 40% OF
THAT IS ORGANIC. AND THAT. IS
THE GROWING SECTOR OF OUR
MARKET- AT THE F. B. NINETY TWO
ADDRESS ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THE
PRESENT PROBLEM WHICH IS IN
CURRENT CURRENTLY A- AFFECTING
THEIR GRANT PROGRAM. THE APPLE
COMING INTO CALIFORNIA ARE BEING
MARKETED AS ORGANIC BUT CAN'T BE
ORGANIC BECAUSE THEY'RE PROBABLY
BEING TREATED WITH SHELF LIFE
PRESERVING PRODUCT THAT IS ONE
OF C. P. THIS IS BEEN CREATED BY
THE NATIONAL ORGANIC STANDARDS
BOARD. APPLE MARKETED AS ORGANIC
COMING FROM OUT OF STATE OR
CURRENT DURING THE SAME TIME
FRAME AS CALIFORNIA APPLES ARE
IN SEASON DO THE DIFFERENCE IS
THE GROWING SEASON THAT SHOULD
NOT BE HAPPY. CALIFORNIA DOES
NOT STORE APPLE. BACK IN SHIFT
FOR APPLE THAT ARE STORED-
DIDN'T MEET THE SAME BREAKS IN
PRESSURES THAT ARE FRESH APPLES
DO YOU HAVE TO BE TREATED WITH
ONE AT THE PEAK. UNFORTUNATELY
ONE MCP HAS NOT BEEN- IN THE
PAST NOT BEEN DETECTABLE. THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION HAVE
DISCOVERED A TEST THAT TEST-
THAT CAN DETECT ONE MCP UP. TO
NINE MONTHS AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
STORAGE- WE AT THE CALVET HAPPEN
ARE WORKING. WITH THE NATIONAL
ORGANIC PROGRAM IN THE STATE TO
CREATE A PROGRAM TO ENGAGE IN
FORMAL MAKING PROCESS TO MANDATE
THAT THIS TEST YOU TAKEN. BEFORE
APPLE SHIPPED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SB NINETY TO
AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION TO ACT AS THE EYES
AND EARS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
APPLE INDUSTRY INSURANCE APPLE'S
MARKET. AS ORGANIC OR TRULY
ORGANIC. THIS WILL SHINE A
SPOTLIGHT ON THE BUT WE TRY
AND THEN TRYING TO SPOTLIGHT ON
THE BAD ACTORS AND REPORT THEM
TO THE STATE ORGANIC PROGRAM. IN
THE NATIONAL ORGANIC PROGRAM.
I'LL BE OUT. WE USE EXISTING
PARTNER. LIKE GROWN TO. STORE
AUDITS IN RETAIL OUTLETS WHICH
WILL. NOT ADD ANY COST TO OUR
CURRENT CALIFORNIA ORGANIC
GROWERS FOR THE CONSUMER-
FINALLY THE NECESSITY OF THIS
BILL TO ENSURE THAT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE CALIFORNIA
ORGANIC APPLE INDUSTRIES THAT
HELP. NOT ALL APPLE PRODUCES OR
HEARING TO FEDERAL AND STATE
LAWS AND REGULATIONS THIS WOULD
ALSO ENSURE A FAR AND EQUITABLE
MARKET FOR ALL PARTICIPATE IN IN
FAVOR OF THE CONSUMERS FROM
IMPROPER LABELING AND MARKING
TAX. AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR
GUYS IT'S TIME AND EVERYBODY-
FOR LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY I CAN
TAKE A QUESTIONS IF THERE ARE
ANY. THANK MISTER CENTERS WILL A
CERTAIN TO- TO REACH OUT TO
SHOULD WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
LET'S MOVE ON ANY WITNESSES- IN
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. DO WE HAVE ANY ANY
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO. SEEING
NONE. ALL RIGHT- LET'S MOVE ON
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
ANY INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE-
WATER IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPTED INDIVIDUALS WITHIN
TESTIFIED SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
EIGHT TWO. LET'S BEGIN. IF NOT
JUST A DAY IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE NINE ZERO. WE'LL GO TO
LINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MISTER TURNER
MEMBERS DELIVER OCEAN WITH A
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU APOLOGIES
WE WERE THIRTY IN OUR LETTER BUT
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT IN HERE OKAY-
ALL RIGHT- LET'S MAKE SURE WE
HAVE ONE MORE SHOT OUT TO-
MODERATOR ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO- COMMENT AND SUPPORT PLEASE
CONFIRM. AGAIN THANK YOU IF YOU
AREN'T OR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT YOU AT THANK YOU. OUR
APPARENTLY WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED FOR S. B.
NINE EIGHT TWO- ANY- INDIVIDUAL
IN. THE ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO NINETY TWO. LET'S
MOVE ON TO TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD IDENTIFY
ANY INDIVIDUALS WE CAN WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE EIGHT TWO. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND
WE HAVE NO OFFICES THANK YOU AT
THE TIME OKAY- SINCE YOU'VE DONE
IT TWICE IN ONE ASK YOU AGAIN-
WHEN WE BRING IT BACK TO THE
DAIS- DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE OF THE- KATIE WISHING TO
COMMENT. CENTER TADA. MISTER
CHAIR- AND THANK YOU CENTER
WHERE TO BRING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I HAVE JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS OUT OF CURIOSITY I DO
IT TO THE SUPPORT THE BILL I
DON'T HAVE ANY ISSUES WITH IT
BUT- THIS IS I THINK- ASSEMBLY.
IN ORDER TO GET A LITTLE BIT
MORE UNDERSTAND. ON THE ISSUE
BUT- DO YOU HAPPEN TO KNOW A
LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT. THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
USING ONE IN. THE IN THE PRODUCT
. MY UNDERSTANDING FROM. THAT
THERE'S SOME OF THAT OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE NOT FROM WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THERE FROM
OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE- BUT
MORE OF WHAT YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT
WE DON'T KNOW THE SPECIFIC
COMPANIES BUT WE KNOW THERE ARE
IN WASHINGTON AS ONE OF THE
LARGEST PRODUCERS AND IS QUITE
LIKELY THAT THAT. OF COMING FROM
AND THEY COME IN THE OFFSEASON-
TO MATCH SORT OF FOR OUR CURRENT
SEASON AND JUST FOR THE RECORD
THIS BILL DOESN'T BAN THOSE
COMPANIES FROM DOING IT IT JUST
MAKES IT CLEAR HOW THEY CANNOT
CAN'T WAIT. CORRECT CORRECT
CORRECT- AND THE REASON WHY I
ASK THIS TO HAVE A SYSTEM GOING
INTERESTED COUNTERFEIT. THE
HOBBIT DIFFERENCE. THAT SO-
THANK YOU FOR THE ANSWER WELL I
HAVE AN ELECTRIC BILL UNDER AND
I SURE OF COURSE. SORRY I DIDN'T
MEAN TO YOU I WANTED TO- BUT
RATE A LITTLE BIT ON AS WELL
PART OF THE PROBLEM WAS. WE
DON'T KNOW THAT AS- A CENTER
WHERE DOES THAT WE DON'T KNOW
THE SPECIFIC ACTORS. BUT WE ALSO
DIDN'T HAVE THE ONE AND THE P.
PATH. TO DO IT NOW WE DEAL AND
SO NOW WE CAN SHINE A SPOTLIGHT
ON THE BAD ACTORS. AND BRING IT
TO THE S. P. N. N. O. P. Q. ACT
AND- REINFORCEMENTS. TO THEM.
THANK YOU MISTER SANDERS. ANY
OTHER MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
ARNOLD JUST HAVE A COUPLE QUICK
COMMENTS. THERE IS VALUE TO THE
WORD ORGANIC AND THERE IS
PRESTIGE TO THE WORD CALIFORNIA.
AND BOTH OF THESE ARE AREAS OF
INTEREST I THINK- HAVE VALUE IN
NEED TO BE PROTECTED BY APPLAUD
WHAT YOU'RE DOING I THINK WHEN
WE HAVE A PRODUCT THAT IS
DEEMED- NON ORGANIC LIKE M. C.
P. IS. THEN IN IT EXTENDS THE
SHELF LIFE CORRECT ME IF I'M
MISTAKEN MISTER SANDERS OR
CENTER LAYERED THIS CAN PROLONG
THE LIFE OF THE APPLE BY MONTHS
IS THAT CORRECT. THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING I WAS SHOCKED THAT
IT COULD THAT IT COULD PROLONG
THE LIFE QUITE LIKE THAT SO
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
SEASONAL- CROSSOVER WE'RE
TALKING ROOM WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
STATES OF PERIOD PERIODS OF TIME
WHERE THEY CAN ACCESS OUR
MARKETS. IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AS
ORGANIC NOT BEING AND- DRIVE ALL
THE BENEFITS SO I THINK WE HAVE
TO PROTECT OUR FARMERS IN THE
IDEA OF WHAT IS ORGANIC AND MAKE
CERTAIN THAT THE PLAYING FIELD
IS LEVEL IF THEY INTEND TO USE-
AND ENTER INTO ARM OUR MARKET
PLACE. MY ONLY CONCERN WITH THIS
AND IT'S NOT GONNA CHANGE
ANYTHING BECAUSE I'M GONNA BE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL IS
THAT WE ARE ALLOWING THIS TO
APPLY TO ONE SPECIFIC SPECIFIC
COMMODITY. M. C. P. SHOULD BE
IDENTIFIED ACROSS THE BOARD AS A
NON ORGANIC- SUBSTANCE SO THAT
IF IT IS APPLIED TO ANY
COMMODITY OR FOOD PRODUCT THAT
IT DISALLOWS THAT ENTITY FROM
REPRESENTING AS SUCH. SO WHETHER
IT IS PAIRS OR ITS YOU KNOW
ANYTHING ELSE IF YOU'RE USING
THIS THIS THIS PRESERVATIVE TO
PROLONG THE LIFE AND APPEARANCE
OF THE PRODUCT. THEN YOU FORFEIT
THE RIGHT TO IDENTIFY IT AS
PURELY ORGANIC SO I WOULD MAKE I
WOULD FROM A POLICY STANDPOINT
WHICH THIS WOULD BE APPLIED MORE
GENERALLY NOT. JUST SPECIFIC TO
AL HOLES BUT THAT'S ABOUT FOR
ANOTHER DAY I SEE. SO I APPLAUD
WHAT YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE DOING
TODAY- AND- CERTAINLY WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE YES AND I WAS JUST
GOING TO ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE BUT
I'LL MAKE A QUICK COMMENT ON
YOUR COMMENT. WHICH IS THAT.
THIS IS WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
STANDARDS. ARE NON ORGANIC AND
THAT PRINCIPLE IS APPLIED TO ALL
CROPS SO IT'S A QUESTION OF THE
OUTSIDE COURTS AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL ADDRESSES AND I WOULD
SUSPECT IF I FIND OUT THAT
THERE'S OTHER IMPORTANCE. OVER
TIME THAT THAT ARE IN THE SAME
SITUATION WE WANT TO DO
SOMETHING SIMILAR. EXCELLENT
ACCENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK OR NOT
ALL RIGHT CENTER TADO MOVED THE
MOTION- ON S. B. NINE EIGHT TWO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROACH. IT'S
OKAY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GORGEOUS I FOR JUST I HER TADO.
FOR TWO I HAVE A- EARLIER I
EGGMAN GLAZER GLAZER AYE. SO IS
THAT FOR- WITH SENT EGGMAN
ABSENT OKAY THANK ALL RIGHT THIS
BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS.
OKAY OUR SECOND AND FINAL BILL
FIERSTEIN COLLEAGUE CENTER COVER
EURO S. B. THIRTEEN OH EIGHT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I'M PLEASED
TO BRIDGE PERTH PRESENT SB
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT WHICH WOULD
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY AND
PROTECT CALIFORNIA JOB BY
CLARIFYING AND STRENGTHENING BY
AMERICAN POLICY FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOL AND COLLEGE MEAL PROGRAMS
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY IS THE LARGEST IN THE
COUNTRY AND PRODUCERS AND
PRODUCES MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
DIFFERENT AGRICULTURAL
COMMODITIES OVER ONE THIRD OF
THE COUNTRY'S VEGETABLES AND TWO
THIRDS OF THE COUNTRY'S FRUITS
AND NUTS AND THIS IS JUST IN
CALIFORNIA. OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE WORK IN
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY FROM FARMWORKERS TO
WORKERS IN FOOD PROCESSING AND
CANNERIES AND FARMERS UNION JOBS
IN CANNERIES IN FOOD PROCESSING
PROVIDE GOOD WAGES BENEFITS AND
RETIREMENT SECURITY TO HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF WORKERS WE HAVE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST LABOR
STANDARDS AND WORKER PROTECTIONS
INCLUDING THE RIGHT TO ORGANIZE.
CALIFORNIA AND EXPAND US GROWN
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES ARE
PRODUCED UNDER THE STRICTEST
REGULATIONS TO ENSURE FOOD
SAFETY REDUCED ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS CAREFULLY MANAGE
PESTICIDE USE AND CONSERVE OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH ACT INCLUDES A BUY
AMERICAN PROVISIONS THAT REQUIRE
SCHOOL FOOD AUTHORITIES. SFA'S
TO PURCHASE DOMESTIC PRODUCTS TO
SERVE MEALS IN SCHOOLS TO THE
EXTENT PRACTICABLE UNDER CURRENT
USDA REGULATIONS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND BYPASS THE
EXISTING BUY AMERICAN
REQUIREMENTS AND PURCHASE
IMPORTED PRODUCTS IF THEY
BELIEVE THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
COST DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN
DOMESTIC AND IMPORTED FOOD
PRODUCTS HOWEVER THE LAW DOES
NOT DEFINE SIGNIFICANT COST
DIFFERENTIAL ALLOWING SCHOOL TO
BY PASS THE REQUIREMENTS. EIGHT
TWENTY SO. REVIEW OF SCHOOL
PROGRAMS BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR FOUND THAT NONE OF THE
SIX SCHOOL DISTRICTS REVIEWED.
HAD ADEQUATE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES TO IMPLEMENT THIS BY
AMERICANS- LAW ALL SIX HAD
PURCHASED FOREIGN SOURCED FOOD
ITEMS BUT DID NOT HAVE ADEQUATE
DOCUMENTATION. TO JUSTIFY THE
PURPOSE THAT PURCHASES AS A
RESULT OF THE BUY AMERICAN
LAXITY CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
PURCHASE LOWER QUALITY GOODS
PRODUCED UNDER LESS STRINGENT
WORKER HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS. DESPITE LIVING IN THE
MOST PRODUCTIVE AGRICULTURAL
REGION OF THE WORLD. THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY HAS FELT
THE IMPACT OVERSEAS COMPETITION
COMPETITION. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SENECA FOODS A PRODUCER OF PEACH
AND FRUIT COCKTAIL PRODUCTS SHIP
SHUDDERED IT'S MODESTO PLANT
PERMANENTLY. LAYING OFF TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE FULL TIME
WORKERS AND A THOUSAND SIX
SEASONAL WORKERS THE COMPANY
CITED IMPORT COMPETITION FROM
OVERSEAS CHINA AND EUROPE AS THE
REASON FOR THE PLANT CLOSURE. S.
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT WILL CLARIFY
AND SO NOT ONLY DID THEY CLOSE
THE PLANT BUT THEY DISCONINUED
CONTRACT WITH THE GROWERS WHICH
THEN BASICALLY- LEFT. LEFT THEM
HIGH AND DRY AS WELL AND SO THE
WITH THE ANCILLARY IMPACT ON ON
THE GROWERS. SB THIRTEEN AWAIT
WILL CLARIFYAND STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S BY AMERICAN POLICY.
BY URGING ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
COLLEGES TO PURCHASE
AGRICULTURAL PART PRODUCT GROUND
PACKAGE ARE PROCESSED IN THE
UNITED STATES. UNLESS THE PRICE
OF A FOREIGN PRODUCT IS MORE
THAN 25% CHEAPER. SB THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT DOES NOT MANDATE WHAT KIND
OF PRODUCT SCHOOLS MUST PURCHASE
PURCHASE ONLY THAT THE PRODUCTS
ARE MADE IN THE UNITED STATES.
SB THIRTEEN AWAIT PROVIDE
SCHOOLS BE A FLEXIBILITY TO
ADDRESS MENUS AND PROCUREMENT TO
AVOID INCREASED COSTS AND GIVE
THEM A SAFETY VALVE IS IF THERE
IS NO AFFORDABLE DOMESTIC
PRODUCT AVAILABLE. BUY AMERICAN
POLICIES INSURE OUR CHILDREN
CONSUME FOOD OF THE HIGHEST
QUALITY AND SAFETY THAT IS
REFLECTIVE OF OUR VALUES BY
SUPPORTING SUPPORTING LOCAL
FARMERS. JOBS IN OUR ECONOMY AS
WELL AS REINFORCING CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT AS A WORLD LEADER ON
CLIMATE CHANGE ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFEGUARDS AND LABOR
PROTECTIONS. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT AS A STATE
EARLIER THE LIMIT WILL BE TWO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION EACH
WITNESS WILL OF TWO MINUTES
TESTIFYING. ALL OTHERS WHICH IS
HAS BY MUSLIM OF THE COMMENTS
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES FOR
THOSE CALLING IN- IN A ME TO
FORMAT- PLEASE LIMIT. IT TO YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION IN
YOUR POSITION- SO THAT WE CAN
MOVE THROUGH OUR CALENDAR- SIR
COVER YOU- YOUR FIRST WITNESS
RICH HUDGENS REPRESENT A
CALIFORNIA CAN IMPEACH
ASSOCIATION. I BELIEVE SO YES
ARE PHYSICALLY PRESENT THERE IT
ALL RIGHT. PLEASE AMONG. THERE
YOU GO. NOVEMBER MPREST FORGETS
COUNTER UP. GOOD MORNING. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'M RECHARGES PRESIDENT
AND CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNING PEACH ASSOCIATION AS A
NONPROFIT FARM COOPERATIVE THE
CCPA IS OWNED BY FOUR HUNDRED
PEACH FARMERS IN CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL VALLEY OUR FARMERS
PRODUCE 75% OF THE NATION'S
SUPPLY OF DOMESTIC AND PACKAGED
PEACH OF PRODUCTION. OUR AVERAGE
MEMBER FARMS FIFTY ACRES OF
PEACHES AND WE HAVE SEVERAL
GENERATIONS OF GROWERS WHO ARE
OF EAST INDIAN DESCENT. WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN OH
EIGHT BECAUSE WILL HELP ENSURE
THE SAFE AND HEALTHY FOOD IN
SCHOOLS BY CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE
IN THE FEDERAL BUY AMERICAN
POLICIES AND PUT CALIFORNIA IN A
POSITION OF CREATING A MODEL FOR
OTHER STATES TO FOLLOW.
SPECIFICALLY IT SB THIRTEEN
AWAIT CLARIFIES BY AMERICAN
COMPLAINTS BY PROHIBITING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. FOR PURCHASING
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS NOT GROWN
PACKED OR PROCESSED
DOMESTICALLY. UNLESS THE COST OF
NON DOMESTIC PRODUCT IS MORE
THAN 25% LOWER. THAN THE PRICE
OF DOMESTIC PRODUCT. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST THREATS FACING
CALIFORNIA'S PEACH FARMERS IS
THE INCREASING. VOLUME OF
FOREIGN CANNED PEACHES ENTERING
THIS COUNTRY PRIMARILY FROM
CHINA AND GREECE. WHAT IS
DEVASTATING TO OUR FARMERS IS
THAT SOME OF THESE FOREIGN
PRODUCTS. ARE PURCHASED WITH
TAXPAYER DOLLARS IN SERBIAN
SCHOOL FEEDING PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA IN ALL OTHER STATES.
PURCHASES OF THESE FOREIGN
PRODUCTS CONTRIBUTED TO THE LOSS
OF FARMS CANNERIES IN JOBS AS AS
SENATOR CAFIERO ALLUDED TO. I
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITIES IS MEETING
EXCEPTIONAL STANDARDS TO ENSURE
FOOD SAFETY REDUCE WATER USE
BOOST ENERGY EFFICIENCY
CAREFULLY MANAGE PESTICIDE USE
IMPLEMENTING CLIMATE SMART
PRACTICES PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
THE WORKERS PROVIDE THE HIGHEST
FORM WAGES IN THE NATION. SB
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT INSURERS THAT
OUR SCHOOL CHILDREN CONSUME FOOD
OF THE HIGHEST QUALITY AND
SAFETY IT ALSO DEMONSTRATES THAT
THE SUPPORT STATE SUPPORT.
LOCALLY GROWN PRODUCTS JOBS IN
OUR ECONOMY IN ADDITION TO AND
REINFORCING CALIFORNIA'S
COMMITMENT AS A WORLD LEADER ON
LABOR AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS. FOR THESE REASONS I
URGE THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
HELP STRENGTHEN BUY AMERICAN
PROCUREMENT POLICIES AND SERVICE
MODEL FOR OTHER STATES TO FOLLOW
. I THANK SENATOR CAFIERO FOR
INTRODUCING THE BILL I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU MISTER ANDERSON HERE- CENTER
CABALLERO MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT YOU HAVE A SECOND WENT
WITNESS PETER FAN FROM THE
TEAMSTERS FOOD PROCESSING
DIVISION- APPEARING
TELEPHONICALLY YES CAN WE
CONFIRM MODERATOR THAT WE HAVE
MISTER FAN ON THE LINE. I AM
HERE THANK YOU MISTER FAN IF YOU
CAN KEEP YOUR COMMENTS TO TWO
MINUTES THAT WOULD BE MOST
APPRECIATED THANK YOU. YOU GOTTA
TAKE IT YEAH THANK THANK YOU
CHAIRED MEMBERS AND- THANK YOU
TO SENATOR ABIERTO FOR OFFERING
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL MY
NAME'S PETER SPENT ON THE
PRINCIPLE OF SERP FEATURES
LOCALLY FIVE SIX RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO THE
NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF THE
TEAMSTERS FOOD PROCESSING
DIVISION. THE TEAMSTERS HAVE ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION MEMBERS
NATIONALLY AND TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA
MANY THAT WORK IN FOOD
PROCESSING OUR MEMBERS TURN
CALIFORNIA PRODUCE INTO CANNED
PEACHES PEARS. GARY PRODUCTS AND
OTHER FOODS ON GROCERY STORE
SHELVES AND IN SCHOOL MEALS
UNION JOBS THE FOOD PROCESSING
PROVIDE GOOD MIDDLE CLASS JOBS
WITH HEALTH COVERAGE AND
RETIREMENT. THE WORKERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAD I AMERICA
REQUIREMENT FOR PUBLIC SCHOOL
MEALS TO ENSURE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
SUPPORT AMERICAN AGRICULTURE.
PRODUCERS AND WORKERS HOWEVER
THE LACK OF CLARITY IN THE LAW
ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO BYPASS
REQUIREMENTS AND BUY FOOD FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES A TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN NEW STORY FOUND THAT.
THE SACRAMENTO SCHOOL DISTRICT
PURCHASED CHINESE CAMP PEACHES
AND MIXED FRUIT EVEN THOUGH
NEARLY ALL U. S. CAN'T BE JUST A
PLASTIC PACKAGE FEATURES. ARE
GROWN AND PROCESSED IN
CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING TO FIGURES
FROM THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF
FARMER COOPERATIVES 81% OF THE
APPLE JUICE SERVED IN SCHOOL
LUNCH PROGRAM IS IMPORTED. AND
5260% OF THE DISTRICTS CERTAIN
TOOLS IF CAUGHT BY RUSSIAN SHIPS
AND PROCESSED IN CHINA. WENT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BY AGRICULTURAL
AND PROCESSED FOOD PRODUCTS FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES CALIFORNIA LOSES
GOOD. JOBS FOR OUTSOURCING HURTS
WORKERS AND THE COMMUNITY THE
DEPEND ON THE AGRICULTURE AND
FOOD PROCESSING INDUSTRIES THAT
SUPPORT LOCAL ECONOMY STUDENTS
ALSO SUFFER CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE POLICY DIRECTOR.
HEALTH FOOD SAFETY ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION LAWS THAT ENSURE A
STATE IN HIGH QUALITY FOOD
SUPPLY. SB THIRTEEN AWAIT
CLARIFIED. AND STRENGTHENED BIG
BY AMERICA REQUIREMENTS BYE FOR.
SCHOOLS FROM NINE AMERICAN.
UNLESS THERE IS A 25% FOR PRICE
. THE VITAMIN. IS MADE BY
AMERICAN CENTER OF THEIR CHEN.
ISSUE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
TOUGHENING REQUIREMENTS FOR
FEDERAL AGENCIES TO BUY AMERICAN
AND APPOINTING A BY AMERICAN
DIRECTOR THE TEAMSTERS UNION.
HAS BEEN ACTIVE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL STRENGTH TO BUY AMERICAN
PROVISIONS FOR SCHOOL MEALS AND
CALIFORNIA HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEAD THE NATION. WITH S. B.
THIRTEEN AWAY FOR THOSE REASONS
I URGE YOU TO VOTE YESTERDAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU-
WE ARE NOW GOING TO MOVE INTO-
AND WITNESSES HERE PHYSICALLY IN
SUPPORT- YOU CAN PLEASE- PROCHE
THE- ALL SORT LIKE TURNS OUT OF
PODIUM IT'S A WHATEVER HIS. HI
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
TRICIA GERINGER WITH
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING OVER
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FARMERS AND
FARMERS AND BUSINESSES FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN OH EIGHT
AND THANK. SENATOR CABALLERO FOR
HER AUTHORS. YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SERAPH LOCKS I AM HERE
ON BEHALF OF THAT CALIFORNIA
CANNERY INDUSTRY- LABOR
MANAGEMENT COOPERATION
COMMITTEE- IT IS A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN- UNIONIZED CANNERY
WORKERS REPRESENTED BY THE
TEAMSTERS AND EMPLOYERS AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT EXCELLENT
ANY OTHER INDIVIDUAL PHYSICALLY
PRESENT WISHING TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE- MODERATOR LET'S MOVE OVER
TO- THE- TELEPHONE LINES ARE
THERE ANY INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. YOU MAY PRESS. ONE
NINE ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN THERE OF YOUR WORK. IT WILL
GO ONLINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING REMEMBER AS
THE STAFF IS VERY WELL WITH YES
OF THE ALASKAN EXAMPLE AND WORK
. THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN MODERATE CAN YOU IDENTIFY
HOW MANY FOLKS ARE IN THE QUEUE.
WE HAVE TO THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MR SHARE MEMBER SHANE
GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL WHICH IS STATE
COUNCIL ALL ZERO AND- IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
THE LINE FOURTEEN LINE IS OPEN.
MICHAEL DEREK REPRESENTING THE-COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
YOU AT THIS TIME YES ONE MORE
TIME ORDER TO PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND THAT'S IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN OH EIGHT
. OKAY ALL RIGHT WE HAVE. GO
AHEAD MA'AM. MODERATOR I'M IN
CHARGE BUT YOU KNOW THAT WE HAVE
NO MORE THANK YOU ARE WE GONNA
MOVE BY USING THE SAME PROCESS
TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS- WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION ANYONE
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE- MODERATOR MOVING ON TO THE
PHONE LINES- FOR THOSE WEEK
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO- SB THIRTEEN AWAIT. THANK YOU
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN
AWAY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT. ALL RIGHT
HEARING ON THE- HEARING NONE ON
THE- ON THE IN THE QUEUE I'M
MOVING IT BACK TO THE DAIS- ANY
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE WISHING
TO COMMENT CENTER GLAZER. THANK
YOU AT CHER BORJAS- I I'D COUNT
ME IN AS A SUPPORTER THIS BILL
I'M HAPPY TO- TO MOVE IT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I CERTAINLY
WANT TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT OUR WONDERFUL AT
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY- BUT I DO HAVE TWO
OBSERVATIONS- ONE IS- THE 25%
NUMBER YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW-
EXACTLY WHY THAT SHOULD BE
HIGHER OR LOWER BUT- IT'S A
POINT OF NOTE. IN THAT SPACE-
SECONDLY- YOU KNOW WE WANT OUR
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS TO BE SOLD
IN OTHER COUNTRIES TO. AND-E.
YET IN THIS FOR THE SPACE OF
ABOUT POTENTIALLY TRADE WARS
BETWEEN COUNTRIES AND THAT'S-
YEAH THAT'S ABOVE MY PAY GRADE
MAYBE EVEN ABOUT THE PAY GRADE
CALIFORNIA- BUT THESE ARE THINGS
THAT HAVE A CAUSE AND EFFECT-
ONE ACTION CAN PRODUCE ANOTHER
REACTION AND SO. I KNOW THAT
WE'RE ALL ON THE SAME PAGE IN
TERMS OF WANTING TO PROTECT OUR-
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY. AND I
HOPE THAT AS THIS- BATTERED WAS
FORWARD AND AS IF IT'S ENACTED
INTO LAW THAT WE WILL WATCH
CAREFULLY TO MAKE SURE THAT. IT
DOESN'T HURT AND OVERALL AND OUR
DESIRE TO HAVE A ROBUST AND
SUCCESSFUL AGRICULTURAL.
INDUSTRY AND WITH THEM AT THE TO
MOVE BUILT APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU. ARE I TO WOULD LIKE
TO ECHO SOME OF THE- THOUGHTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES. RARELY DO
YOU SEE AN ITEM THAT. BRINGS
TOGETHER LABOR BUSINESS AND
NATIONAL SECURITY. AND I THINK
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE- RARE
ITEMS. WHERE LABOR BENEFITS BY
HAVING A CONSTANT SUPPLY OF WORK
AND GOOD WORKING CONDITIONS-
BUSINESS- PROSPERS BECAUSE- WE
REEMPHASIZE OVER AND OVER AGAIN
THE IMPORTANCE OF AGRICULTURE
AND EXPAND. OUR OF OUR
PRODUCTION CAPACITIES AND TO
BRING TO THE FOREFRONT- HELD
PORTENT INDUSTRIES FAR TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY PROVIDING
ADMINISTRATION THROUGH BILL
BACK- AMERICA. I THINK HAS
APPROPRIATELY IDENTIFIED THAT
BUYING AMERICAN IS A SOUND
POLICY SO LONG AS IT'S DONE
FAIRLY AND ALLOWS OTHERS TO
COMPETE IN OUR MARKET PLACE JUST
AS WE WISH TO COMPETE IN OTHER
MARKETPLACES. I DID ASK THE
CONSULTANT AND- THE AUTHORS-
STAFF- TO LOOK INTO WHETHER OUT
THERE IT WOULD BE ANY ISSUES
WITH NAFTA- AND ANY OTHER FREE
TRADE- AGREEMENT THAT WE MAY
HAVE THAT COULD INTERFERE OR
OVER STEP FROM AN AD FROM A
STATE STANDPOINT INTO A NATIONAL
AND INTERNATIONAL STANDPOINT. I
DON'T KNOW IF THE AUTHOR HAS ANY
COMMENTS BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT- THERE IS NO- PROBABLY
PROBLEM WITH NAFTA OR ANY OTHER
FREE TRADE OBLIGATION WE HAVE
YES AND THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
OF THIS REALLY COMPLIES WITH
THE- WITH THE PRESIDENT'S- BY
BACK AMERICA- PROGRAM IT IT'S
ALIGNED WITH IT AND IT DOESN'T
ON IT OUR UNDERSTANDING IS IT
DOES NOT- TRAMPLE ON ANY OF THAT
WORLD TRADE ORGANIZATION
GUIDELINES OR OR ANY OF THE-
OTHER TRADE- REQUIREMENTS THAT
WE HAVE. AND THERE THERE'S NO
QUESTION THERE'S ALWAYS IMPACTS-
AND THIS DOES NOT STOP THE
IMPORTATION OF PRODUCTS. FRESH
FRUIT AND VEGETABLE PRODUCTS
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES IF THAT
HAPPENS ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
QUITE FRANKLY DURING THE WINTER
TIME ALMOST ALL THE FRUIT AND
VEGETABLES THAT YOU U. P. COME
FROM SOUTH AMERICA. SO IT
DOESN'T STOP THAT BUT WHAT IT
DOES DO IS IT FOCUSES. TAXPAYER
DOLLARS. AND SAYS IF WE'RE GOING
TO BE USING THESE TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO FEED PEOPLE WHICH IS
WHAT WE DO WITH OUR SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM FOR SCHOOL FOOD
PROGRAMS. THAT THAT WE OUGHT TO
BE PRIORITIZING AMERICAN MADE
PRODUCTS UNLESS THE PRODUCT IS
SO MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE THAN THE
FOREIGN PRODUCT MORE THAN 25%
SO. THAT THAT'S WHAT IT DOES
AND- ACTION ARE UNDERSTANDING
THAT IT IS NOT. WE'LL KEEP AN
EYE BALL ON IT AS IT MOVES
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THE DATA
UNDERSTANDING IT IS TRUE AND
THAT WE ADDRESS THE BILL IF.
NEED BE. YOU KNOW I ALL ALL
THESE POLITICAL- SLOGANS I THINK
I MADE A BOO BOO. I CALLED IT
BUILD BACK. I INSTEAD OF BUY
BACK OKAY I CAN'T KEEP TRACK OF
THESE. THE MINISTER BUT- THE LOT
I THINK I THINK MY- MY LAST MY
LAST POINT IS THAT- THERE WILL
LIKELY BE I SUSPECT SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES- YOU
KNOW. LAWS OF RECIPROCITY IN
COMMERCE EXIST AND AS WE MOVE IN
THIS DIRECTION AS I BELIEVE WE
SHOULD. WE SHOULD ALSO
ANTICIPATE THAT THERE MIGHT BE-
SOME FENCES OR SOME WALLS PUT
UP- FOR OUR PRODUCTS MOVING
ELSEWHERE SIMILARLY SITUATED BUT
ULTIMATELY I THINK THIS IS SOUND
POLICY THAT WE SHOULD BE
INVESTING IN OUR IN OUR WORKERS
ARE FARMS- IN OUR PRODUCTION
CAPACITIES. THE NOTION OF
BUYING- RUSSIAN CAUGHT COD- AT
LONG JOHN SILVER'S AND DRINKING
APPLE JUICE FROM I DON'T KNOW
WHICH COUNTRY BUT PEACHES FROM
CHINA- THAT ENTIRE. ALCHEMY
DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT IN MY OPINIONWHEN WE HAVE IN OUR BACKYARD SO-
WITH THAT BEING SAID- CENTER
COVER YOUR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I YES MISTER CHAIR REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY HAD
THIS CONVERSATION- WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT YOU CAN'T YOU CAN'T
BUY THOSE PRODUCTS AT LONG JOHN
SILVER'S BUT WE'RE SAYING IS IF
YOU'RE GOING TO GO INTO A SCHOOL
CAFETERIA THAT THAT PRODUCT I TO
BE AMERICAN MADE. ON S. B.
THIRTEEN OH EIGHT IT IS TO PASS
BUT- BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GEO CONSOLE
PEOPLE'S CULTURAL SURE. FORGES
HI FORGES. HURTADO CABALLERO
CAREER I EGGMAN GLAZER GLAZER
AYE. CAN WE RECALL THE ROLE NOW
THAT- WE HAVE ANOTHER MEMBER
COMMENTS SURE.
HER TARA. HURTADO BY SO FOUR
ZERO ONE WITH CENTER EGGMAN
ABSENT OKAY- WHERE'S THAT
RECITAL THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
BILLS ON CALL CORRECT. ALL
RIGHT- THANK YOU INDIVIDUALS-
FOR ALL THE INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATING PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY LIKE A WESTERN THEY JUST'S
GRANDDADDY HERE. IF YOU'RE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY DID YOU SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE AG COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT AS
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORD THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA SENATE
COMMITTEE ON AG IS A GERMAN.